I have friends that work in private
Equity they work in big law firms they
work in investment Banks they are
working really hard really long but
there's so much dead and inefficient
time which would kill me as a human
being one of the reasons that I can be
comfortable with working so hard and
committing so much is the work is highly
efficient it's async I can call people
when I when I need to call them in a
human way I can call them when I'm
walking my dog if I had a dog but I can
call them when I go and get some fresh
air right that type of thing is really
really meaningful in some in some
environments
the formalized touch points of meetings
have become so important and so
significant that it becomes the only
touch point to connect with people
properly connected people that's a
disaster
yeah
all right guys bang bang I've got Daniel
here Daniel you are the ultimate
entrepreneur in the sense of you've had
to do a ton of crazy things in order to
help build deal into this Behemoth doing
hundreds of millions of dollars of
Revenue and one of the things that I
know you guys have had to do is go to
many many different countries to help
set up all sorts of legal entities I
think at one point you guys are even
carrying a physical printer with you
talk a little bit about some of the like
unscalable things that you've had to do
to build what everyone looks at from the
outside is this like really sexy
fast-growing company but really it's
just a collection of small unscalable
things that you guys have had to figure
out as you've gone
yeah so I think first thing to realize
is the deal really is like any other
international corporation we have
headquarters parent company and we have
subsidiaries across many different
countries around the globe and a lot of
those countries it's pretty easy to go
there and set up for example you can go
to the UK you can go to the UK
government's website and you can set up
a company in a pretty easy way
you go to Argentina you go to Brazil you
go to Malaysia that process is very
different most the time you have to
physically be there you have to
physically be there go to the Secretary
of State yeah you could have an attorney
do it but sometimes they actually
require that director to be in that
country and then you need to print out
all this documentation so we literally
had a team of people that would go
country to Country prepare these
applications and then we would file them
and in some cases the directors which
are me the CEO the CFO would have to
actually physically be there so that
meant we would fly around country to
country with a little HP printer in our
luggage arrive at the hotel room plug it
in print off the documentation meet with
a notary and then go to the secretary of
state to file documents to incorporate
the company or obtain a relevant labor
license
so what's always interesting to me is
whenever somebody has this kind of
entrepreneurial DNA and you see it later
in life especially as they become more
and more successful with various things
that they build you can almost trace it
back right and for you you grew up on a
farm I believe and that's really kind of
where you learn entrepreneurship and
then throughout your Early Childhood uh
you did a whole bunch of entrepreneurial
things which we'll get into but talk a
little bit about growing up uh and kind
of how you learn some of these skills
and really focused on just like how do
you solve problems and build you know
what ends up being businesses in an
entrepreneurial way yeah sure I mean a
great great point I did grow up on a
farm I'm a small town boy and my dad was
the farmer that I'd wake up from an
early age maybe 10 years old and I would
I would work with him every day and I
think the farm taught me a couple of
things maybe three things which are
really important the first thing is hard
work prevails now my dad as soon as his
eyes open he's up he's out of bed he's
working and he's doing something and I
learned that and applied that in
business
second thing is every journey is made up
of many different steps and those steps
can be as small as you want I think
about
planting seeds growing a crop harvesting
that crop sending it off to a mill to
finally manufacture bread bread that you
eat at home there's so many steps in
that process
um and that's the same in business and
entrepreneurialism
um every kind of idea needs to be broken
down into so many different steps and
you follow the steps and eventually you
get to where you're going and I think
the final thing is diversification or
ability to Pivot all of the farmers that
I met in England and these are small
town Small Town Farmers these are not
big corporate Farms it's a very very
small little places in England all of
them diversify maybe they have some
crops in the ground maybe they have some
livestock maybe they have some people
that keep horses on the land maybe they
have other things going on and my father
would constantly diversify his business
to survive
let's talk about once you leave the farm
and you start doing all sorts of
entrepreneurial things uh one of them is
this like I'll call it we work of
parking lots uh which is just an
absolutely insane story but like what
were you guys doing with parking lots in
your teenage years
well yeah I wanted to find a place to
park my car in Newcastle which is where
I went to school is my local city and it
was really tough to find a parking spot
in the urban area the same as it is in
New York or any other major urban city
so anyway found a parking spot it was
great I paid the owner um 120 pounds a
month or whatever it was and then I
quickly realized well there's a ton of
other vacant
parking spaces in the local area so
maybe I could rent those spaces I could
negotiate pretty good rates similar to
what I'm paying on a kind of long-term
lease and then I could sub rent those
spaces to commuters or other people that
were visiting the city for shorter
amounts of time and I did that I think
the first step I found another parking
space rented it for 120 pounds a month
and I thought well if I don't sub rent
it it's okay I have an extra space maybe
I have friends come and visit whatever I
don't care I signed that lease rented
that space and within I think one day I
had someone that wanted to lease it from
me for um for 12 weeks at significant
markup and we repeated that across many
different parking spaces and it was
really really good fun
so when you're doing that is it like Hey
how do I just become like a parking
Empire right like like the king of this
parking Empire or is it more so you kind
of understand hey this is great right
now we can make some money but
eventually I want to go and do other
things
yeah I think for me to go to go and lay
it deeper uh I quickly realized that I
wasn't going to become the person I was
flipping parking spaces in Newcastle
England and to be completely transparent
about it at that time The Social Network
movie came out I watched that I loved it
and thought wow you can build businesses
which are backed by Venture capitalists
and raise a huge amount of money and
build businesses which can produce a
huge amount of money and at that point
in time I realized
um I don't want to be flipping car
parking spaces I want to work for one of
these companies and that's where I found
revolute which was my first proper job
and as you are working there it's
obviously uh with revolut this
intersection of kind of like Finance
technology talk a little bit about what
you learned helping to scale that
business to the size it is today
um if I kind of think about fundamentals
um
very similar to what I learned growing
up with my father I think the things
that I didn't learn growing up but did
learn in in revolut are focusing on the
problem at hand everything that we are
doing should be building towards solving
a problem problem for the customer or a
problem for an internal service
I think the second thing that I've kind
of learned a revolute which I did not
learn in my earlier days
is that
um collaborating and working and tiring
other smart like-minded people
produces a compounding effect of of
working like we didn't have that in in
the small town days right you were
limited with working with a small group
of people
working at a venture-backed business you
can bring smart people together that buy
into your vision and then accomplish uh
huge things very quickly yeah that makes
a that makes a ton of sense and one of
the things that I think revolute you
know it almost feels like you've
expanded over time right so you've got
the farm then you're kind of in
Newcastle then with revolutely now
you've got kind of a bigger uh you know
kind of more diverse group of people
that you're working with but with deal
what uh when you and I have talked
previously that you told me which I
found absolutely fascinating is I think
you have colleagues in like 80 different
countries and so you can pretty much go
to like almost any city in the world
that has some level of density and
there's likely to be a deal employee
that works there that you could meet up
with
exactly and it extends past major cities
and extends to I would say other
interesting places for example I was in
Uruguay in January meeting with one of
our partners
um we're in Punta Del Este which is a
holiday destination vacation destination
in the middle of Uruguay and we have
guilty for that it was great we went out
for dinner
um we went over some work stuff we were
relaxed we socialized it was super cool
but yeah we have teammates over 80
different countries so as you think
about your rise and kind of the
connectivity you have globally it really
does mirror what we've seen over the
last 150 years or so like some of the
books that I've read in the past you
know there's this book the rise and fall
of American growth and it talks about
between uh kind of 1870 and like 1940
and how you know a home was basically
self-reliant and had to have food it had
to figure out water and like do all this
stuff by the time he gets to the 1940s
everything's connected with roads and
Telecommunications and now there's
specialization whatever but also if you
then you go and you look around those
same times there are these organization
missions that have been built over you
know 100 plus years take a Cargill which
is a huge uh you know business here in
the United States and what you see with
that business is that they literally
start off as like a grain family like
they are providing grains and storage
for grain and then now you fast forward
them like they do everything from
clothing all the way to you know uh
equipment Etc and so it's almost as like
as the world has become more connected
it feels like uh there has been more and
more Economic Opportunity capitalism
kind of seeps into all these corners but
with deal you all are solving this like
very specific problem with which is like
yeah it's great to do Commerce with all
these other countries but what if you're
actually going to be employing people in
all these other countries and kind of
talk a little bit as to like how you see
this connectivity and the rise of
Internet adoption and all of that really
driving the need for the business and
product that you guys are building
well I think globalization isn't
editable and
um people are going to live in different
places and that should not
constrain who they're working for I
firmly believe that
um there should be no borders when it
comes to the talent and to work and
that's really what deal is here for our
mission is to connect millions of
workers with the best companies around
the world
and we do that
we we and we do that through uh software
we have one platform where companies can
hire on board and manage their Global
Workforce
so when you look at that product today
how many of the companies that you all
are onboarding are like the two three
person startup that is trying to scale
rapidly versus it's the larger
corporations and how do companies kind
of evaluate uh should I hire
quote-unquote locally right whether
that's locally to a City a state or even
a country versus no I actually should go
and have kind of employees across the
globe
yeah I think startups really are
finding the best talent the talent is
choosing the the startup salary choosing
the town it's I have Founders Friends of
the founders that have recently started
up and they find something that they
want to hire they don't care where
they're based they don't care if they're
in Canada Mexico Argentina or China like
they really don't care they just want to
hire the person and they want to hire
them as quickly as possible
I think when you get to the large kind
of Corporation stage then the business
is much more strategic about where it
wants to hire and there's typically
um time zone factors in there there's
cost factors in there there's risk
factors in there
um there's working style and culture
factors in there and we've seen that for
for for decades if not centuries we've
seen large Fortune 500 companies
Outsource part of their their Workforce
to different countries and the term
Outsourcing is never really used
entirely correctly it might be that that
is a big office in India for an American
for looking 500 company but it's not
actually outsourced those people are
working for let's say it's Bank of
America they're working for Bank of
America and Bank of America's India
subsidiary
when you see these companies is it more
productivity is it lower cost is it just
hey the best people regardless of cost
uh like what what is really driving
um kind of to the business bottom line
and I always go to like yes everyone
talks about hey I want the best talent
right I want the best people but the
best people can be measured in many
different ways the best people could be
I want people who can get the job done
and cost me the least the best people
can be the most productive the most
talented uh that could be the best
educated like what are you seeing as
these people are hiring and also are you
seeing certain Pockets around the world
where it seems like maybe there wasn't a
lot of attention being driven there uh
by these large companies that were
hiring and now there's an explosion you
know in the content world the
Philippines has become like this huge
Honeypot of uh video editing Talent Etc
but are there other types of Trends or
locations that you guys are paying
attention to
first of all startups are going for the
best talent we see that time and time
again they really don't care they just
want the best person and they want them
to start as soon as possible
and we get to the big companies
I think there's two buckets here they
also want the best talent but it's not
for all roles maybe they want the best
talent for their sales or their business
team but they don't necessarily need the
best talent for some other
um function maybe it's a Services
function maybe it's back office they
don't necessarily the best in that
scenario we're seeing companies be much
more strategic and almost surgical about
where where to hire and that's really
where VP of Finance CFO comes in because
frankly when you're running a startup
scale up not that many people are
watching the bottom line that's the
reality of it everyone might pretend
yeah we're watching the bottom line with
cross-watches whatever the CFO vpa
Finance are really the guys that are
looking at it
um precisely and they're going to make
strategic decisions of yes we're going
to hire in this location or this time
zone now to your final point of those
kind of Honey pots of expertise yeah
that's the really cool part and we're
seeing that in let's say Argentina a lot
of cool
um ux UI talent in Nigeria we're seeing
a lot of good technical operations
talent that are working in tooling
applications automations OR tech support
really really cool stuff coming from
um Nigeria and then sales America
remains to be the Holy Grail of the kind
of global Sales Machine we see so many
companies from Europe wanting to hire
American Sales people because they want
to expand over here
when you see all of this Talent what is
their thought process so like let's
switch to the the employee side of this
uh they've got skills they have internet
access they have some entrepreneurial
DNA because they want to go work at a
you know kind of a smaller startup you
know the Challenger rather than go try
to get a job at IBM for example
um how many of these people are looking
at the startup roles is simply like hey
that's my training ground that's my
practice for eventually I want to go
start a company versus you see people
wanting to stay for long periods of time
at these companies and and one of the
things that uh I think is important here
is like if a lot of these folks are
trying to learn and they want to go
start companies are we going to see this
explosion of kind of startup activity we
see in the United States spread globally
as well
yeah
I think great question the first thing
to note is deal has been really
successful in the grand scheme I think
we're still tiny with a tiny number of
heads on the platform relative to the
global population and what that means is
the people that are using the deal
platform and finding work through the
deal platform from these Emerging
Markets let's say Greece for example I'm
going to Greece soon I say I'm a young
guy in Greece I'm going to use deal to
find my next job
by virtue of using deal and knowing what
deal isn't
um using it to find my job I am
a one percent type of person I am very
entrepreneurial I want to work harder I
want to grow myself I have growth
mindset but that's really really
interesting
um as deal gets larger and gets more
saturated in certain countries for
example in Argentina deal is very well
known we do big deal events down there
with the community
um
generally deal is very highly regarded
in Argentina and that's when you kind of
get that Honeypot type of effect it's
like oh well actually there's a
community now of ux UI developers
professionals that are using the ultra
fine work and their Community people is
really really strong
you have a ton of young people who reach
out to you you're relatively young
compared to most people who are in your
type of role at you know large companies
um and sometimes they're asking you for
like career advice maybe sometimes
they're pitching you ideas what are some
of the most interesting things that
you've seen people working on recently
yeah it's something I'm certainly
passionate about I started off in my
tech Journey age 21 initially was a
customer support guy I did customer
support for a few weeks and I got top of
the leaderboard and then went into Ops
um so yeah I'd love to work with young
people and and help them
um
um I think that within deal we have a
number of people that fit these
parameters and we've watched them grow
over the past three or four years which
has been amazing and some of those guys
are running
end-to-end programs now at the company
in different areas or one guy for
example responsible for the full
um payout payout stack payment to that
payments to contractors he runs the
whole program it's freaking amazing he
does a great job and it's just amazing
to see that person join the company as a
very inexperienced somewhat nervous
individual grow into this competent
program manager that owns a part of owns
a moving part of the business today
that's really cool externally yeah ton
of people reach out and would love to
would love to listen to everyone but
reality reality is you can't
um I think there's been some really
interesting stuff in crypto
um it's fun to seem to die down a little
bit now given we have ai as a new Hot
Topic but a ton of interesting stuff in
crypto
um and a ton of projects which which I
guess caught my my friend's attention
when you think about kind of uh
information that you've consumed that
has made you so successful one of the
books I know that you like is the messy
middle talk a little bit about that book
and kind of the importance behind uh the
information that you gleaned from it
yeah I think in conclusion the messy
middle
gives you an element of reassurance
when things get really messy really
hectic
I refer back to that point of many
different steps in in a journey you know
hundreds different thousands of steps in
this journey and it could be your honest
certain step and the thing is just crazy
it's so messy things are breaking
relationships aren't working people are
falling out and you're in the messy
middle
and what that what that book is really
telling you is the messy middle is what
is signifying progress without all of
that mess
and without being in the middle you're
not progressing you're not growing that
that book is really good at giving
reassurance and helping me communicate
that reassurance to the wide receiver
bill
when you think of that book specifically
are there pieces of uh kind of
information you pulled out and then can
you talk about like a specific situation
a deal where you feel like you
implemented it and can kind of say like
oh I got that from that book
sure
um I'm gonna grow with
um payments to contractors so
to set the scene a contractor might be
using the deal platform to raise their
invoices and get paid very typical for
startups or for cross-border and working
Arrangements Sam in turkey and I'm
working for us company I'm gonna invoice
that company I'm gonna get paid for it
now we like to give the contractors or
we do like to give
um the contractors a range of payment
methods let them choose how they want to
get paid they can get paid to the deal
card they can get paid to their PayPal
wallet they can get paid to their bank
account
one of the issues we had is we were
giving these contractors too much
optionality we're saying hey you can get
paid through any different payment
method you want and some of those
payment methods
were not fit for purpose
what I mean is for example bringing
pounds or Euros as currency into turkey
just isn't wasn't working the banks in
Turkey were porting the payments they
were screening the payments and the
contractor wouldn't get their money
within the time frame they expected
so when this was going on we have
contractors which loved taking euros and
pounds to Turkey we have other
contractors which aren't getting their
money on time it's creating a lot of
noise we have people writing in on
customer support it's like boom this is
hella messy and we have people at the
company that want to keep bringing euros
and pounds of turkeys with contractors
love it you have other stakeholders like
let's shut this down because it's
causing too much friction and you're in
the messy middle
and you have to work with those
different stakeholders and find the
optimal solution and we found it we
found the solution which continued to
give the contractors the options that
they want to get paid but reduce a lot
of that really messy overhead and some
of those complex cases which produce
delays
so along these lines people who have
had an operating background they have
done an incredible amount of good things
but also made plenty of mistakes and
usually when they're making decisions
they actually don't know if it's a good
decision or a bad decision they hope is
a good one but you kind of don't know
until you have the benefit of hindsight
is there anything that in your career
you're like hey I made a decision it was
the wrong decision but here's what I
learned from it or here's how I identify
it I won't repeat X or Y and I think
about this a lot in terms of when bad
things are happening I always try to
stop and say like what's the lesson here
and so you know I'll give you an example
uh first which is we were hiring an
employee and uh for one of our
businesses and they verbally committed
to us on a Friday and so we went and did
a bunch of work uh Friday night and
Saturday you know get all the
documentation and kind of work through
it by Sunday night they hadn't signed it
yet but we had already started to talk
internally and let people know okay hey
this person is going to be joining us
here's the the changes we're gonna make
whatever and by Monday morning they say
you know what look my heart's just not
in it and so we had to basically put
together the standard operating
procedures around like okay at what
point do we actually share with the
broader team that's how much joining or
not joining is it if they signed or not
like there's all these lessons that we
learned but it came out of a situation
where like we're like look we wish it
had gone a different way and so is there
something like that that you've been
able to identify where you're like yeah
this is kind of how I went through a
process and was able to take out some
insights and make sure that I didn't
repeat those mistakes in the in the
future
yeah first of all we have the exact same
case with deal well we had to lead a
joint really really excited really great
guy but last minute heart wasn't in it
wanted to do something different and we
had to tell everyone it really sucked so
we also have to upgrade and develop out
those Sops
um
it's a tough question
to Spring to on a podcast if I'm honest
um
what do you think your biggest career
mistake has been how about that like if
you could go back and change one thing
you're like if I could do that again I
would have done something different well
biggest career mistake is all around
hiring it's about bringing people into
your circle to work on the same project
and submission so if it was the biggest
mistake I would literally pinpoint
certain people that we we brought in to
our Circle to work on the project which
didn't work out if we if we analyze
scrutinized entity better
made better decisions we would have done
more and like there's multiple people I
obviously I'm gonna say their name is
multiple people I can I can speak to and
think of immediately if they if we
hadn't spent
four weeks five weeks six weeks
interviewing getting to know them and
then another similar period of time
onboarding and then working with them
for four months and then making the
decision to off-board them
that's so much time wasted that is the
number one thing
yeah and it always goes back to I think
it's full of a node coastla is like you
know the team you build is the company
you build and so you're trying to get it
right but the process you just described
there are four to six weeks of
interviewing four to six weeks of
onboarding and then four months later I
mean you're basically talking about six
to seven months from start to finish uh
and to most people that's gonna sound
like an insanely short period of time
right but actually in the startup world
that is like two lifetimes in terms of
not having the right person because then
once you know that you've got a off
board that first person you gotta go
find the actual person who's gonna fill
the role and so it ends up extending
that time frame uh pretty significantly
I think in interviewing it's really
important to trust no one and it's don't
trust yourself don't trust the candidate
don't trust their references in this
case got a reference saying he was the
smartest guy the referee had ever met
um he was very very confident and very
very sure it was the right right role
for him and that made me feel confident
um that he was the right person
I should have brought in more
third-party stakeholders cross reference
cross analyze
um and then when you have all that data
there you can actually say well this
person probably isn't right for us yeah
and when you're going through those
interviews how do you kind of get people
to uh tell you the truth right and I
always say in terms of I think in
interviews most candidates are trying to
put their best foot forward obviously
like they want to impress the
interviewer they want to get the job
like there's all these reasons and
personal incentives that that take over
um but how do you try to get at you know
who is this person going to be not on
day one but on day 747 and like that's
who we're actually trying to hire is
somebody who's great on day 747 not the
person who comes in on the first day you
know they're kind of dressed up extra
special they show up 20 minutes earlier
than they normally would and like
they're trying to put their best foot
forward on day one because they're
enthusiastic but how do you get at that
in an interview
I think Break Down The Professional
paywall first and foremost break that
down as quick and efficiently as
possible
and start to have a human conversation
with the person and it doesn't start and
stop with the interview all of the exact
hires that I make and that I am
currently recruiting for it's a whole
process we are iMessage WhatsApp will do
off the cuff calls we will have the
professional touch points where we have
an hour-long interview where we speak to
each other over camera in a very formal
and professional way but that can't be
it especially for an exec hire you
really need to understand the person you
need to understand their level of
interest you need to understand their
level of commitment working at a startup
is an incredible level of commitment you
need to work so hard and stay focused on
the goal it's not for everyone and
there's no way that you can accurately
read that in an interview type scenario
when you think about uh the startups are
not for everyone what is the day-to-day
schedule of somebody at deal are you
guys still working you know 12 14 hour
type days has it scaled back as you've
gotten larger talk a little bit about
um kind of that experience on a
day-to-day basis because I think when
people hear it's not for everyone
they're like oh it's just a different uh
you know Mission or different industry I
don't think they sometimes understand
how different it is working at a startup
versus even working at Facebook or
Google let alone you know kind of a more
bureaucratic and Bloated uh you know
non-tech type company
yeah I think in too long didn't didn't
read kind of format yeah we still work
really really hard there's no doubt
about it
um
I have friends that work in private
Equity they work in big law firms they
work in investment Banks they are
working really hard really long but
there's so much dead and inefficient
time which would kill me as a human
being one of the reasons that I can
become full with working so hard and
committing so much is the work is highly
efficient it's async I can call people
when when I need to call them in a human
way I can call them when I'm walking my
dog if I had a dog
um but I can call them when I go and get
some fresh air right that type of thing
is really really meaningful in some in
some environments the formalized touch
points of meetings have become so
important and so significant that it
becomes the only touch point to connect
with people to properly connected people
that's a disaster that is so expensive
for the company that constrains time and
productivity so much uniquely working
fully async you need to be trusting your
entire team it doesn't matter if they're
taking a call while they're outside
getting some fresh air it doesn't matter
if they're taking a call while they're
eating their lunch because they're on
the go and they have a tight schedule it
doesn't matter if they're taking a quick
call before they jump on a plane it's
all about trust and working working
asynchronously
and in that environment how much is it
systems and like documentation and stuff
like that right if you if it is this
async type environment like
communication is still important but
async communication is obviously
different than uh kind of synchronous
communication like what are some of the
systems that you guys have tried to
install or things that you've seen work
really really really well whether it's
for you personally or for the company
I loot back to the messy middle for a
moment I think you can have a lot of
informal fluid conversation and note
taking in a pretty unstructured way as
long as that is underpinned by structure
then you're fine and that's how we
generally work a deal we can work on
these hot topics for two or three days
at a time it's very very fluid it's
pretty messy frankly there's different
phone calls going on that's different
um Google meets forums different
documents but the point of it is at the
end of the project everything is
formalized and put into an sop or a
standard
um organizational structure
and so as you see that occurring one of
the pieces that I always kind of go back
to is it's kind of like uh software
Engineers there's a lot of software
Engineers that can write amazing code
and do it very quickly and then there's
a lot of software Engineers who can
write amazing code and do it with the
proper documentation and notes and kind
of like understand they're working in a
bigger organization and so it's like
clean code that can be used later by
other people and and did not have to
call me to figure out what was I doing
or why did I make certain decisions like
how much of the company today is like
just write code and you know ship it
right or whatever the equivalent is for
each job role versus it's like no we
need to go quickly we need to have high
quality work but we also need to be
focused on those operating processes you
know documentation and that type of
stuff
early stage startup is always a mess
Engineers pushing code very quickly no
proper QA no proper documentation it's
just get it out deploy to production if
it goes down we'll fix it and no one
will notice
you know running a business the size of
deal on the platform the size of deal
you cannot do that it's incredibly
dangerous and everyone is watching
everyone there were tens of hundreds of
people using the problem every minute
I think that once a startup gets to a
around
um 50 200 people
not saying you need to use headcount as
a d metric but the sum metric that you
could use around that size
the engineering processes become robust
those checks and balances are in place
documentation is happening everything is
very clean and organized
we're two and a half thousand people now
so we have startups within startups all
of that kind of stage so you have those
global Sops guardrails checks and
balances but at the end you have many
different product teams which are run
like startups with kind of a mini CEO
which is responsible for the error of
the product and responsible for pushing
it forward
I think uh when I ask my friends who
have large teams you know hundreds if
not thousands of employees one of the
things that uh they still find a lot of
enjoyment in is sometimes they will see
an update get pushed or uh they'll see
some sort of uh product feature get
shipped and they're pleasantly surprised
because they're like I would have never
thought of that but like this team is
doing a great job or uh hey we hired
really high quality people who thought
differently than myself or my
co-founders or whatever and what you're
describing here with almost like these
small startups within uh the company I'm
assuming that you guys get a lot of that
because if you sit all day and you just
think about this one you know part of
the product you probably end up thinking
more deeply and critically about it then
let's say you know somebody who spends
five seconds uh once a week and tries to
figure out what we should do there
man that is the best feeling seeing one
of those teams produce something which
you have no oversight over you don't
really know what's going on like you
know the objective you know what they're
working towards but you don't know how
they're going to meet it and then they
produce this product and you're like
wow that that's fantastic I wouldn't
have built it this way I couldn't have
built it this way that's killer like
that is the best feeling
yeah I think uh I think that is shared
across every company that I talk with
um Enzo Ferrari is uh a world famous
entrepreneur uh although some people may
not think of him that way
um I know that you've thought a lot
about you know his obsession with just
like building a beautiful car talk a
little bit about like his rise and
building a Ferrari and and trying to
make it perfect and maybe the corollary
is of like how do you think about the
craft and like what you all are trying
to do and the obsession that you have in
solving your problem
it was a friend that was speaking
about this to me and he basically said
if you want to build a car from a
spreadsheet that's what Ford have done
and if you want to build
a car to become a piece of art that's
what Enzo Ferrari did I think that's
that's like a very fascinating notion
that you can go one of two ways and
maybe there's some kind of hybrid in
between
um and I think that you don't want to be
full full spreadsheet right you want to
make sure there's some
um artistic license uh given to the team
so they have agency to make really cool
creative decisions and build things
which are more than just
um uh a spreadsheet yeah it also feels
like I guess you know Ford
um is uninspiring like nobody I don't
think anyone gets in like a Ford
Explorer and they're like wow right they
get in and they're like this is a great
vehicle for what I need to accomplish it
gets the job done it's durable it's
reliable it's you know all of these
types of things
um but the Ferrari is a whole different
uh you know kind of experience I think
uh what's interesting to me is like
maybe Tesla and again there's some
people who love Tesla some people who
hate Tesla whatever but like maybe
they're one of the companies that's
trying to like be the middle how do you
build something that's beautiful and
inspiring and kind of captures the
imagination of you know a bunch of
people but at the same time can they
drive the price down you know to sub 50k
versus having to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars on a sports car
first of all I'm a big admirer of Elon
Musk I think he's fantastic he's an
amazing entrepreneur and I think Tesla
is an amazing product I don't have one
myself
um
but I would like one Teslas are great uh
very very cool
um very super cool technology
yeah uh and and I guess part of uh this
idea of like building off a spreadsheet
versus building off of you know kind of
an artistic desire uh it also depends on
the company right like if you almost
think about uh deal to some degree like
you all probably sit down and look at a
map and you're like okay like what are
all the countries that we need to be
able to be operational in and then the
idea of like carrying the physical
printer into the country like that's not
a spreadsheet right that's like more the
art and somebody probably was like Hey
I'm tired of you know running around
trying to find a Kinkos or whatever the
local equivalent is instead we can just
plug our own in and go ahead and print
documents there how big is it does it
fit in my bag is it heavy you know like
you just kind of figure it out and then
you have this great story to tell but
actually it was highly efficient and
effective for fitting back into kind of
that spreadsheet type uh approach of
like what are the countries we need to
be operational in
I think it's also closely correlated
with culture and attitude I have people
at the company that work with me and
they're amazing but culturally they're
just not gonna take a printer from the
country to country with them they would
say no they're just not going to do it
for me I'm totally fine
um so that culture and background can
also Drive approach and I think that's
why you hire say Your Design creative
team from a certain culture from a
certain background with a certain
mindset so they can make those decisions
and then you hire your Ops guys with a
slightly different mindset so they can
really focus on accurate operational
delivery how important is it to have
people from both of the cultures like
the people who would say yes I'll carry
the printer and the people who say no I
won't do it like is the diversity of
culture important or actually do you
wish that you had more people who would
carry the printer uh rather than less
I think diversity is so so so important
and we're so diverse
this weekend we've had people
celebrating Easter Passover Ramadan and
probably some other stuff I don't even
know about that that first piece so it
wasn't even so close to what we are a
deal and has had a huge impact on what
we've built yeah I always find it
interesting as well uh given that the
business is international you know when
I worked at Facebook in 2014 2015 like
it's easy to get caught in oh I'm a
United States citizen sitting in uh
Menlo Park and we're building products
and like let me check out uh what this
feature looks like on my iPhone on you
know uh whatever it was 3G you know uh
internet at the time and then they
literally built this like testing uh
kind of facility and what they did is it
allows you to use uh all kinds of other
different mobile devices and they were
able to throttle the internet connection
and so you could literally see like what
is this product or feature look like on
a you know T9 texting nonstop smartphone
device if I was in a rural part of X
country
and you're like yo that looked real
fast and cool on my iPhone this is a
nightmare on this other device how do we
solve and kind of make it work on both
right
yeah I have a crazy story related to
this topic so former boss his name is
Vlad CTO at revolut it wasn't my direct
boss but he was one of the bosses of the
company
he's worth a ton of money he built
revolutely he's still to this day at
least last time I saw him still to this
last time I saw him he uses a really old
shitty Android phone like the like the
the worst phone I have ever seen right
to turn the screen on if I had to wake
up I'm pretty sure it takes two or three
seconds and he does that because he
wants revolute to run perfectly on the
worst attack Possible Oh that was
amazing the the um uh you know the word
empathy I think has like become kind of
this like weird thing that everyone
wants to run around and yell and scream
about but like that's ultimately what it
is right it's like if I put myself in
the seat of the people who are gonna
have the hardest problem in accessing
our technology and I'm able to solve it
for them then we're going to be
excellent for the people who have you
know great uh internet uh great devices
all this stuff
um but but also it's not just the
technology right like I think one of the
other pieces that's really interesting
um is when you're dealing with uh
employees being paid I know Uber for
example had a huge uh kind of Challenge
and when they went into India in a
couple of other countries like there is
not a credit card culture and so if it's
heavy cash like how do you deal with
that and then not only how do you
actually like process the payment but
then like how do you prevent the driver
from stealing the money right and like
you kind of like deal with all like the
fraud mitigation and things like that
but also if if you think about
um the the idea of like when do people
get paid right in the United States I
think most people get paid twice a month
you know there's kind of like this like
cultural uh agreement but I've got to
assume that maybe I'm wrong you can
correct me but like I've got to assume
that around the world the way people get
paid in terms of you know uh Bank
deposits or whatever how often they get
paid like all that stuff changes on a
country-to-country basis and so you all
have to understand that in order to
actually serve the customer correct
a totally typically the schedule which
people are paid changes whether it's
twice monthly once monthly sometimes
it's post kind of in arrears five days
after the end of the month
but salary payments aren't the biggest
variable it's onboarding onboarding an
employee you think about onboarding here
in the US it's pretty easy you get all
of that kind of employees key
information social date of birth you run
a quick immigration check with the US
government service they sign their
employee humor and they start
you go to certain countries medical
tests the employee has to go to a doctor
and have a medical assessment that needs
to be passed and certified before they
can start work
military service certification they have
to prove that they've completed military
service we have the vet that we have to
validate that and I think the most uh
interesting one is immigration we help
employees from different nationalities
work in different countries
it is uh it is fascinating to me where
in the United States if you said to
someone hey you got to go to the doctor
before you come work here that would be
like taboo and may even be like that the
headline of a you know hit piece article
saying like can you imagine this company
is doing this in another country it's
mandatory and just like when you now
have this connectivity uh where
individuals can work at companies not in
their country uh it really changes not
only uh the employee expectations but
reverse right and what you guys help
with is like now the companies have to
go learn around the globe what are all
these requirements that we have to
fulfill in these countries and so it's
almost like a complexity on both sides
and I think a US company probably is
like hey this is making your life harder
but actually for an employee who's
getting a job at a us-based company
maybe it actually is making their job
easier right like they actually see it
as oh I don't have to do all these steps
that maybe I would have to do if I
worked at a local company and so it's
very fascinating how the same exact uh
kind of uh Trend can be seemed as a pro
or a con depending on which side of uh
of the marketplace you are
yeah the biggest Delta for me is the
company that's hiring the person they're
head of HR VP of people or whatever they
typically know
HR in the home country and maybe you
wanted to other countries really really
well it's really rare to find a people
leader that has experience over many
different countries and that produces a
deltar in expectations because maybe
they know how to onboard off-board do
PTO rollover in the US the UK Germany
but they have no idea how it really
works in Malaysia they have the
fundamentals assuming that the systems
are fundamentally the same but really
they don't know that's where the biggest
Delta comes from got it okay that makes
uh that makes a lot of sense
um talk to me about what advice would
you give yourself 10 years ago like you
now have been working in tech for about
10 years what what are the things that
you wish you knew when you started
I think when something is
something is going badly
the time
to react to that bad thing should be as
short as possible at this stage in my
life when something is going wrong I'm
very quick to react whether it's in
personal life professional life whatever
can react very quickly and we can
produce change and we'll basically try
another way of solving that problem and
doing that thing maybe it'll be better
maybe it'll be worse hopefully it'll be
better
maybe it'll be worse then we try again I
look at my kind of younger self 24 year
old self
fat time to make the decision to change
was much longer so
the sooner you can shorten that thinking
time to make a decision the better
so it's almost like uh from hey I should
do this to like action or execution the
shorter that time period you think just
the the faster that you're able to get
things done and kind of Drive uh output
and productivity
it kind of but it can be a little bit
deeper than that it could be
relationship based maybe you've got a
higher
someone on the team is looking after a
certain program or a certain area of the
business oh well
you know I think pomp is great but um
I'm just I'm just not sure if he's if
he's going to grow I'm going to be here
in six months and doing doing the right
thing there's a few issues with this
program and you speak to him and then
you try and say like well I think you
need to do this this better you need to
change your workflow that
and then a couple of moments ago and I
haven't probably paid enough attention
to make sure that things have improved
and then you know we get to a point in
time where you're super dissatisfied
with the job because you're not
succeeding and not having a fun time I'm
super satisfied as the manager if we'd
actually made that decision to
take action sooner and
pay close attention to what's going on
probably wouldn't be where we are today
so I think that's a really good example
yeah and I think that that is a a
situation that people experience across
the world right it doesn't matter if
you're in a tech startup if you're in uh
kind of a Fortune 500 you know more
bureaucratic company or literally you uh
could potentially just be working I
always go to the extreme example like
you could be working on oil pipelines in
Texas and there's someone there who's
the manager who's like hey I wish that
that person would do X and that person's
like man I really don't enjoy the job
right now and so I think that's a great
lesson that applies across across
different businesses
um my last question for you is if you
weren't working at deal what would you
be doing oh
that's a really tough question to be
honest I don't think about this too much
because I'm really happy working a deal
so I don't think I have a good answer
for it I would like to think I'll be
working on something that's a really
scalable
B it's International and C it has some
type of good social impact
that's a great answer because although
you don't know what it is you kind of
have a framework to evaluate what it
would be which I think kind of speaks to
the fact that you've got a pretty good
sense of what you enjoy doing and kind
of what are the things that you're going
to be working on so I think that's as
good of an answer as anyone can give me
um where can we send people to find you
on the internet or find out more about
deal
uh deal.com
I'm on Twitter I'm on LinkedIn uh
posting pretty frequently so that's a
good place what is your Twitter handle
do you know
uh don Westfield all right we'll send
some people over to Twitter and uh
hopefully we can get more more content
out of you all the operational uh
insights and uh uh secrets that you have
we need to spread because there's not
very many people who have uh employees
that you know thousands of employees
across the world 80 different countries
hundreds of millions of dollars in uh in
Revenue you guys are doing an absolute
killer job of scaling this thing and
operations is at the heart of it so I
appreciate your time today I learned a
ton I think a lot of the audience will
have learned a lot as well and uh we
will definitely do this again in the
future
thanks appreciate it